some of the the misconception that
people might have when they look at the
things that i've done on paper
in any given year is that i'm doing them
all at the same time
and the truth is that i'm trying to do
one of those things really well in any
given moment and then
excellently transitioned to the next
task
and i think that in that year it kept me
healthy as an athlete
to end practice at a certain time
and to not have practice last all day
because as you and i know you can run
for
several hours but you can't run all day
but some people let that happen whether
it's mentally or physically
and so in some ways ending practice
and just worrying about how are we going
to fund this movie
was a a blessing to my olympic
trajectory as well because
you couldn't just sit and stew
and and obsess about things that you
don't have control over like it allowed
you to shift gears and
and stay fresh with both things because
you had other pursuits outside of just
that singular
focus yeah and and it even simplified
running because if if i
thought about how challenging it was
going to be to do this workout
uh i could also have the perspective of
how simple it is that i
just need to keep putting one foot in
front of the other when
it felt like so complicated to try to
put together a feature film so i think
the feature film people dynamics you
know
how how what it takes to put a movie
together is so different than what it
takes
to just keep running when you're in a
mile repeat right
and likewise the pain of
doing that mile repeat or doing multiple
was very painful compared to the ease of
sitting on a couch and making
phone calls or writing a script which is
hard
but it's not like my body hurts while
i'm doing it so i think
they were um tweedledee and tweedledum
to each other just playful each and
their own right are so overwhelming
there must have been moments where you
just felt like this i'm climbing
you know a mountain that is double the
size of everest
yeah it felt it felt hard
i have a great partner too you know like
i do have jeremy with me
and i was never pulling all-nighters
while my
goal my number one goal was to go to the
olympics
so i think part of it and perhaps you
can relate is knowing
what is the priority in any given moment
and always knowing what my north star
was
and then everything needs to fall under
that so like
the i am going to sleep
at least eight hours a night and that's
like non-negotiable
even if we need to stay up late editing
there's a time when i need to stop
right um so maybe those boundaries
are um are more clear because i knew
what the
priority one was and priority two but it
was stressful
like but it was stressful
in like a thrilling way because
i was playing a game running and i was
making a movie
and also no one's ever done anything
like that before which is kind of
exhilarating
and intimidating i would suspect um and
i'm sure
you get the balance question all the
time like how do you balance your life
and i i hate that i don't
look at life in that context it just
seems confusing to me like it seems my
sense is that
it's more with you it's more about
synergy like are these things in synergy
with each other do they feed off
of each other do each one of these
things make me better at the other one
do you feel like you're thriving right
it's like more of a feeling and what how
do you answer it when people ask you
that question
i mean i used to feel i used to feel
guilt and shame because my life just
is not really balanced in that
traditional sense and i would
strive to make it fit into those
buckets and at some point i just let go
of that whole thing and
you know look in the in the macro and
i'm sure this is the case with yourself
in the macro your life is very much in
balance but you're shifting gears
between
intense focus on different things that
give your life
meaning and you know make you excited
when you wake up in the morning but
to the average person on a day-to-day
basis
it would appear that you're very much
out of balance yes okay
now i feel like i understand what you're
getting at because there were people
during that time
who were like i think you and jeremy
should take a break and like go camping
this weekend like i think you guys need
a night off or like i'm
i'm i think you need i think you should
i think and that was like
you know i was at an age where it was
like i felt a little weird about us like
i know i'm living in oregon
and there's so much great camping but
all i want to do is work on these
projects like i
i was so happy being so
overflowing with with what i was doing
and i feel like what you're saying is
similarly you you like
live to work but your work is your
choice and your work is your passion and
so it's your pleasure
to have this like bubbling cauldron
that someone might look at and and not
think is
healthy yeah i mean there's that but
it's also
the intensity that you bring to whatever
it is you're doing like if it's an ultra
endurance race or you training for the
olympics or trying to execute on a
feature film or me
you know doing what i do here i get joy
out of being totally immersed in
whatever it is that i'm doing
and i'm not effective unless i can say
no
to other things and blot things out so
that i can
give my best but that means that other
things in my life that are important to
me
aren't getting adequate amount of
attention on that particular day so
the gear shifting is important such that
everything in my life
that i care about is attended to
properly it just doesn't happen
on an hour to hour or day to day basis
necessarily
[Music]
you